they were very pleased to have you on
alternative views tonight and I think
we're going to have an opportunity to
tell our audience all the things that
they wanted to know but we're afraid to
ask about smoking cigarettes the tobacco
industry because you've been researching
these topics for years and have come up
with all sorts of new information that's
generally not known to the public so
let's begin by telling some of those
people that are puffing out in the
audience what are in those weeds that
they are getting such pleasure from well
they are getting a lot of pleasure out
of their cigarettes affect each person
who has a favorite brand is getting his
own specific brand of pleasure for one
thing because there's a whole each brand
has a patented set of chemicals in it
which generically in the industry are
known as smoker satisfaction chemicals
and they are specifically designed to be
mildly physiologically addictive as well
as to be to to acclimatize the tastes of
the smoker to the particular taste to
the brand it's the reason why the smoker
of one brand a runs out of brand a and
bum's brand B off a friend that might
last and for a little while but as soon
as that smoker of brand a can get to the
Machine he'll go ahead and buy brand a
again he's addicted to it you know I've
talked to people since we talked to
several weeks ago I've just checked you
smokers I say what do you ever try any
other cigarettes they say you know I try
this other cigarettes but they sure
don't taste good I like my own brand
Zack ha ha exactly and that's just one
what is it that they're addicted to is
it the tobacco or the specific chemicals
well there's that there's a whole set of
answers to your question unfortunately
I'll try to keep it short for one thing
certainly they're addicted to nicotine
nicotine is a component of cigarettes
mostly nowadays the nicotine that's in
there is not in there as a result of
being on a natural tobacco leaf it's in
there because and the manufacturers have
incorporated it as an ingredient in the
synthetic smoking materials that most
cigarettes are made out of now then of
course there's a form of addiction
that's generally not discussed with
cigarettes but it's a real factor and
that is that cigarettes contain so many
extremely toxic ingredients that are put
in there as
all of manufacturing decisions they're
not they're not in any natural tobacco
that may have somehow found its way into
the cigarette so there's a toxic
addiction when you take a small amount
of a highly toxic substance into your
body on a chronic sublegal basis your
body develops an addiction to it you
stop stop ingesting that toxic chemical
and your body I'll go through withdrawal
but overall pleasure what are some of
these things that they put in well for
instance one one of the main areas of
contamination in cigarettes is the
solvents utilized to drive the flavoring
chemicals and the aroma chemicals and
the smoker satisfaction chemicals into
the cellulose of the synthetic smoking
material they have to carry those
chemicals into this alpha cellulose
which is recycled municipal waste
recycled forest industry product waste
that kind of stuff it's basically basic
cellulose so they have to use solvents
to to carry these flavoring chemicals
and so forth into the Alpha cellulose
they use things like benzene toluene and
cyclohexane they also use one of the
more common solvents and I have copies
of the patents for the utilization of
this is phosgene that's nerve gas that's
exactly right
it's a very effective solvent as well
and residues of it remain in the Alpha
cellulose after processing is through
and so when the cigarette is smoked when
the synthetic smoking materials burn in
addition to the release of chemicals
that are naturally accompany the
combustion of organic materials you get
a release of such things as phosgene and
benzene and when as benzene that's a
known carcinogen to cisely yeah exactly
one of the main reasons that that the
cigarette industry and you really need
to distinguish between the cigarette
industry in the tobacco industry one of
the main reasons that they are able to
say it's never been effectively proven
or scientifically proven that cigarettes
cause cancer or heart disease and so
forth well it actually hasn't ever been
scientifically proven and that's
primarily because the cigarettes they're
utilized by NIH and
all the other testing organizations in
conducting their rat skin painting tests
and all that sort of thing are
especially supplied to them by the
tobacco industry and their university of
kentucky standard 100 millimeter
cigarettes and they are composed of pure
tobacco there's no synthetic smoking
material there's no benzene there's none
of the processing chemicals utilized in
these cigarettes that are smoked by the
machines and then painted on the mouse
skins and so forth so there's there's an
elaborate set of reasons why the tobacco
industry or pardon me the cigarette
industry is still in the face of
common-sense able to maintain this this
glib disingenuous attitude well nobody's
really proved it no in fact there's many
different kinds of tobacco and even
pesticide residues that get into
cigarettes it's not a pure sweet leaf
that you sometimes see in the south you
know hang it up to dry and you see in
all the ads you see in all the ads tell
us a little bit about junk tobacco you
guys have pesticide residues you better
get into tobacco and add to the poison
here well in addition to synthetic
materials synthetic smoking materials
which today comprise a large portion of
most brands of cigarettes you have
what's called reconstituted sheet
appropriately-named and it is it's
composed of roots and stems and trash
tobacco trash brought into this country
by the cigarette manufacturers primarily
from third world sources and utilized
it's ground up into a fine powder and
it's incorporated along with glues and
flavoring chemicals and so forth into a
sheet that looks it looks like a piece
of plywood or particle board which is
then shaved in giant Mills and that's if
a person who's smoking cares too and a
lot of people would rather not know
which is one of the reasons like that
perhaps sets are clicking at this very
moment but for those who are listening
who care to take a take a cigarette cut
it apart and look at those little golden
curls under magnification and you'll see
that they're not parts of leaves
there's no veins in them you know but
what you can see is you can see they're
composed of little fine particles
that's ground-up roots and stems
those tobacco plants in the third world
where they were originally raised were
sprayed with all kinds of pesticides I
have research that has been done in
Europe that indicates that there are
dozens of pesticides many of which are
totally banned in this country DDT
chlordane hepta Clorox Fein D ldren
Aldrin endrin on and on end of soften a
wide range of pesticides that have known
fetus damaging effects there are
chemicals that are specifically designed
not to kill bugs because bugs generally
in the tropics now you can't poison them
there they're immune to poisons so you
have to go after them genetically and
they either these chemicals are designed
either to go after the adult bugs to
mess up their reproductive systems or
the third level of pesticides being used
in getting on to tobacco and getting
into the roots and stems and being
brought in and made into remanufactured
sheet in this country there are even
chemicals designed specifically to
produce non-viable insect offspring and
this works then it's magic through
cigarettes and the people that we we
don't know but it's on I think it's
really unlikely that all the damage to
fetus is being experienced by by smoking
mother's is due to carbon monoxide
nicotine you think it's these chemicals
as well well I think it's reasonable to
assume that if you're ingesting six
different chemicals and three of them
are known fetus damages and carcinogens
and three others you don't know what
they are they may or may not be I think
it makes sense to focus on the things
that you know are there what about
filters are filters on the cigarettes
able to keep some of these poisons and
cars and nicotine from entering the body
in some cases certain types of filters
yes the governments of Europe the
governments of the European Economic
Community have for the last 20 years
recognized that this is a really severe
problem pesticides in cigarettes and
they have extensive regulations in place
in Europe in fact you cannot bring
tobacco into Europe for manufacture into
cigarettes that has a DDT contamination
that has any
most of the organochlorine pesticides
are totally banned in Europe on tobacco
products and as a consequence any smoker
knows you smoke brand a in the US and
you go to Europe and buy brand a at the
airport and in the train station
wherever it tastes very different and
that's because it's made with tobacco
for one thing a relatively little
reconstituted tobacco is president
European cigarettes simply because they
can't get enough uncontaminated material
to make the cheap substitute with so
they have to use the real thing what
about other tobacco products like cigars
or snuff right to chewing tobacco well
in terms of pesticides each has its own
specific kind of danger cigars for
instance the really good cigars wrapped
in real genuine tobacco leaf remember I
mentioned before the program that one of
the things about tobacco's it's very
high in sugar and insects of course are
very attracted to plants they're high in
sugar and plant high in protein
consequently when you're raising cigar
leaf tobacco in the tropics you have a
real real serious problem with with
insects biting holes in it and that
makes it unacceptable as wrapper leaf
even worse you have a problem with
snails and slugs so there's a wide range
of snail and slug killers which usually
incorporate heavy metals that are
utilized on cigar wrapper leaf tobacco
methanol if you're familiar with
pesticides is probably the most common
and highest level contaminant of cigar
leaves chewing tobacco snuff wet snuff
which a lot of young people are turning
to particularly as an alternative to
smoking is extraordinarily dangerous
from the standpoint of oral cavity
cancer primarily because several of the
pesticides used in the production of the
junk tobacco basically the trash tobacco
that's used to make this stuff are very
high in things like ndel a which is a
known oral cavity carcinogen there is an
extreme danger really in using this web
snuff this Sean Marcy case up in
Oklahoma that was just lost a few months
back if his mother and his lawyer had
had access to this information
they should have tried the case in a
whole different area because the
manufacturers are guilty of knowing that
these chemicals are present in
cigarettes and tobacco so-called
products well have you gotten all this
information a lot of Freedom of
Information Act a lot of just plain
reading industry literature the industry
is totally unregulated they don't have
they don't have to comply to any federal
or state regulations with regard to what
they put in their products or what their
products are contaminated with so they
chatter back and forth a great deal in
their technical papers I have a list of
a computer list sent to me by EPA and
this is a printout of all the tobacco
industry studies done on the effects of
pesticides in creating off taste they're
very concerned about consumer acceptance
problem they don't care about the health
problems worried about this well they
don't they don't study the health
problems because if they did study the
health problems then they could it could
be said that they knew about them what
does off taste me oh if it tastes any
different than what the consumer is as
usual is accustomed to each brand has a
very specific set of taste buds it goes
after in a very specific set of aromas
in fact there are specific chemicals in
there designed to give you that first
aroma that comes out of the pack when
you open it that's a specific chemical
in each brand or set of chemicals then
when you pull the cigarette out and put
it in your mouth there's another set of
chemicals that are designed to draw you
further into the use of the product it's
a very well thought-through product well
you mentioned that in Europe they had
regulation in the tobacco industry
against using pesticides on tobacco
exactly and that the industry is not
regulated in the United States or to
oversee any of these things you're
talking about that are in cigarettes why
is this the case we think of ourselves
as a modern progressive society how come
we're so far behind the rest of the
world in regulating the cigarette
industry that's a that's a good question
without any without an answer that can
be given authority to lead but I can
point to a couple of things
the
tobacco industry built America I mean
tobacco money provided the capital for
the maintenance and development of the
majority of the first colonies and
tobacco as a trade item was
extraordinarily important it earned its
producers of vast sums of money that
were instrumental in developing the
United States really it has the in terms
of a corporate product the tobacco
industry has the HA the cigarette
industry has the highest internal rate
of return on invested capital of any
industry anywhere and it's just simply
number one violet by a long long margin
the diversification of of the capital
that's been earned by the cigarette
companies over the last half century has
brought them into ownership of just
about everything that you can think of
on just about any level they're not into
being obvious Empire builders so you
don't see organization charts really
very often but inside the tobacco
industry I've pieced together an
ownership network of the capital and it
even pennant it penetrates a long long
way for instance the Mary Babcock
Reynolds foundation is a prime funder of
Ralph Nader's Public Citizen group the
and that's tobacco related oh yeah
Reynolds Reynolds so yeah sorry I said
I've never done an expose of the
cigarette industry actually I got a very
interesting I went to a very interesting
interesting back and forth with the
editor of Public Citizen about a year
and a half ago they he wanted to do a
sizable expose based on this information
that's the Nader Mack the Nader magazine
right but when it rose to the level of
the editorial board dr. Sidney Wolfe who
is their principal of medical authority
I was told that his objection to doing
the story was well I raised the issue
that might lead people to say well maybe
it isn't the tobacco that's causing all
the trouble maybe it's all these
chemicals and so maybe smoking tobacco
would be okay which is part of my
premise really I'm not certain
that smoking tobacco is that bad for
people who want to smoke tobacco edits
the cigarette industry Frank I might
note that we interviewed George's eldest
on alternative views who wrote in fact
that was the first US magazine to
explore some of the dangers of tobacco
or rather cigarette smoking and Selda
said that no other magazine journal and
newspaper in the United States would
publish an article critical the
cigarette industry because of the amount
of advertising that went into all of
these different media from the cigarette
industry that was one of the major you
know spenders of advertising revenue
along with I think alcohol and cars and
so none of these dangerous industries
are could be investigated simply because
whoever did that would lose advertising
revenue even more conspiratorial if you
want to see things on that level which
is often hard not to the fact is that
it's not just cigarette advertising that
controls the media the cigarette
companies own alcohol they own food
processing they own transportation they
own a great deal of media itself they
own food processing companies so in
other words if they if a magazine or a
piece of print media or electronic media
is about to do something that is
effectively dangerous to the to the
industry the advertising pressure can
come from all kinds of directions I mean
del Monte is owned by RJ Reynolds you
know I mean it's one of the biggest food
conglomerates in the world sure and how
many del Monte ads are in a magazine you
know and Kentucky Fried Chicken Hugh
blinds you know I'm just not about
Congress I mean we know about Jesse
Helms being the tobacco
he's the clown upfront designed to keep
us from from understanding the depth to
which tobacco money really controls and
penetrates you you don't in terms of
Congress I haven't seen anybody yet who
is willing to take on the not just the
cigarette industry but the economic
power that the industry in all of its
aspects
but the fact is that 350,000 people a
year are dying of smoking cigarettes
we've got untold numbers of babies being
destroyed from birth by cigarettes we've
got a tremendous social and economic
costs the equivalent of three 747s
crashing a day you know and it's and
it's an industry that is in effect been
given licensed by the government to
produce a product that's doing this in
other words the the the government knows
very well what the position of the
European governments is on the issue of
pesticides because our tobacco farmers
raised the tobacco that's me that's made
into cigarettes in Europe because we
have strong pesticide regulations in
America so the American government the
Department of Commerce Department
Culture helped us farmers tobacco
farmers raised relatively pesticide free
tobacco to meet European standards while
at the same time allowing the cigarette
industry to bring in third-world tobacco
for manufacturing the cigarettes that
Americans are smoking and everybody
along the way knows what's going on but
nobody's dealing with the issue there's
never been a single study of the effects
of pesticides in tobacco or cigarette
products by any of the major US health
research foundations not one
how do you explain this I mean you told
about the strange conditions of the
scientific unquote experiments using
just pure tobacco rather than what
people really smoke right you would
think there would be universities or
independent health agencies or
scientists who would do some more
serious investigations by this there's
been one his name is dr. Dietrich
Hoffman he was ahead of Sloan Kettering
Cancer Research Institute
when dr. Hoffman started doing research
on the role of of pesticide chemicals in
oral cavity cancer in wet snuff tours he
within 12 months for variety of reasons
was no longer with sloan-kettering
apparently had an extremely hard time
finding any place to get his research
published he is now he is now working
full-time for the Dana Family Foundation
in Valhalla New York
all places in the American Health
Foundation and doing recent in Ewing to
do research into the role of pesticides
in oral cavity cancer but all his
research is being published in Europe
and in Russia and China he speaks all
over the world but he can't speak in the
US nobody wants to hear him so there
really is a conspiracy I don't know all
right with you can't see the conspiracy
all you can see is the results of and
you can infer there must be something
going on well what you mentioned trying
to get your information in the native
publication what about other print media
or electronic media if you had any luck
in getting them now I really haven't a
number of TV shows a commercial
television people have heard about the
research I've been doing have approached
me have shot a lot of tape edited it out
had visions of awards I'm sure for
revealing this terrible dark murderous
conspiracy and then nothing has happened
when when it's risen to the level of
editorial on the station and this
happened with the station in Houston and
it's happened with several other
stations on the level of print media
it's very interesting I'm a published
author I guess I've sold probably about
a million books in my lifetime a million
of my books have sold and once I have
sold but and my I'm a good agent and New
York agent he took my manuscript to the
Frankfurt Book Fair where and he got a
call from World Health Organization in
Geneva they flew them down and they said
if you can find a publisher who will
publish this book anywhere we will vet
it for you we'll provide the people to
vet it to make sure there's no technical
mistakes that way you set it out that a
manuscript check it out make sure that
there's nothing inaccurate in there
technically that can be seized upon as
an excuse your criticism right they said
that their World Health Organization is
very aware of the problem they
considered major major problem but for
various reasons no government
organization can address it either so I
was real pleased that you guys and he
should check under the hoods of your car
tonight as I will we can get you British
publishers
a lot of presses in England would
probably be happy to but it seems to me
it's a supreme irony here we're talking
about all the bad stuff that smoking
tobacco etc or what people think is
tobacco will do to you and yet on the
other hand I've read articles where it
says that pure tobacco can be one of the
greatest boons to mankind because in its
role as food well there's a lot of
there's a lot of been a lot of research
in that area and it's a couple of things
that that that to say that maybe will
keep that from sounding so strange
tobacco is an extremely high protein
plant in terms of plant proteins it's
more complete than corn or beans or
anything else and young tobacco when
it's just a green chute is extremely
high in sugars as well animals love it
in tobacco country you can't keep rabbit
and deers you know another grazing
animals a cattle out of your tobacco
beds so the the notion that tobacco is
if you treat tobacco is just another
plant then you can sort of get away from
the idea that well wouldn't it kill you
to eat it because it won't and what what
you're talking about Frank is a series
of experiments that have extracted
protein in its pure form from tobacco
and utilize it and feeding experiments
and it's been very successful and
there's a man in North Carolina Turman
the crop science department there who's
been raising tobacco just for that
purpose he's been raising biomass how
much tobacco can I get on an acre and
he's achieved yields of 200 metric tons
an acre a year of tobacco very high in
protein and he's almost got enough
protein out of an acre of tobacco that
it's cost-competitive with dried eggs
which are a major source of protein in
animal feeding so this goes back to a
lot of Indian customs wasn't tobacco a
major part of a whole lot of economies
yeah really what different people all
over the world it was considered a gift
of the Great Spirit one of the four
great gifts and it was a tobacco is a
very powerful plants full it's got a
very powerful plant spirit the concept
of the Hindu
concept of diva spirits in plants the
the diva spirit and tobacco is an
extraordinary one I've had Indian
tobacco plants that I've grown that I've
cut off at the soil line when they were
blooming in the fall and then I've hung
them upside down in a dark basement
without water dry atmosphere for six
months and come into the basement they
just they'd be turned up at the tip and
blooming and the seeds I was growing we
were out of a grave that was 800 years
old and I got fifty percent germination
such a remarkable plant in a lot of
respects but it's one that's been
severely abused by the cigarette and
exactly mixes all these chemical
pesticides and synthetics in there but
what can be done about this there have
been some product liability suits people
have sued the tobacco colonies because
they claimed that it killed their
relatives from cancer or whatever what
has been the fate of that and how do you
see these cases it's really been sad
because the over 300k over 300 product
liability cases have have been tried
have come to trial and gone through
trial in the past approximately 10 years
and every single one has been won by the
tobacco companies and it's in I am NOT a
legal scholar but it seems to me from
looking at the cases and I've read as
many of them as I could get ahold of in
none of the trial testimony concerned
raising the kinds of issues that I've
brought out in this research which would
be really important if you're going to
establish the company's liability for
producing an unreasonably dangerous
product most testimonies concentrated on
on one line which is this industry is
manufacturing products that contain an
addictive material and my client got
addicted to using these harmful products
and since he couldn't stop the
harmfulness of the product harm to my
client and therefore the company's
liable and that line doesn't wash as far
as product liability law goes what you
have to be able to do is you have to be
able to prove that a manufacturer
knowingly or unknowingly manufactured an
unreasonably dangerous product
and that you were in some way or another
deprived of information which would have
made a difference in your decision to
use the product and nobody has been able
to prove that with regard at the tobacco
industry pardon me I see I keep saying
it I'm an example of the of the
fundamental subtle perception that keeps
us from doing something about this
industry I keep saying the tobacco
industry they're not they're not tobacco
it's a cigarette the cigarette industry
the chemical stick industry poison
industry it sounds like they know that
there's these poisons oh they do in in
pocket equity really and toxic
carcinogenic fetus damaging nerve nor
all different forms of biological damage
well ultimately what would you propose
doing about this obviously you want to
get information out to the public
yeah so in product liability suits there
can be judgments against the a backhoe
industries that will cause some problems
for them what is your ultimate solution
well my ultimate solution I would like
to see something of something modeled on
the Nuremberg trials I think the tobacco
the cigarette industry is too
multinational and too powerful to be
effectively tried by any single
government just like the Nazi fascist
movement was too international you know
to be tried by any one government I
think that the industry's assets should
be stripped from it and I think that
they should be distributed to those
who've been injured and then should be
put in a trust fund for those who you
know who will continue to be injured
over over time by this but I also think
that that an awful lot of people have a
right to smoke tobacco and I think a lot
of people would enjoy having a tobacco
product that they could smoke there's
certainly a great many farmers in this
country and around the world who growing
tobacco for them growing tobacco is what
they know now that tobacco doesn't wind
up in the cigarettes and what happens to
it's another long story but there's too
many long stories involved in this in
this whole issue but I do think the
industry needs to be disassembled and I
think that in its place a new industry
needs to be erected based on small farm
production of a high quality smoking
product for people who want to smoke